[Musique]
il en faut du courage pour oser déclarer
sa flamme
encore plus quand on est un enfant
mélanie le rendez-vous des juniors nous
fait rencontrer emile emile c'est un
jeune garçon amoureux de louise depuis
la maternelle très timide il n'ose pas
le lui dire
mais problème il n'a plus qu'un jour
pour lui avouer avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard
emile et ses parents vous en fait
bientôt déménager et comme il est trop
timide
il fait demi tour et en retournant en
classe il trouve une boîte bande annonce
il était une fois
dès 1985 donc les enfants vous savez
très bien qu'il n'avait pas l'âge ici
dix ans et moi nous vend le mieux ça
fait 19 dépêchez vous bonjour tout le
monde
bonjour monsieur maurice on a ri voir ma
place j'ai trouvé qu'une petite boîte
posée sur mon bureau je voulais juste
dire à emile j'espère que tu es chaud
pour ce soir moi je suis comme une
marque
[Musique]
alors son histoire est à découvrir à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois christelle la
responsable nous donne quelques
informations supplémentaires
c'est un spectacle très original dans sa
main dans sa dans sa conception c'est un
concert live il ya cinq musiciens sur
scène mais aussi une projection vidéo de
dessins animés avec des détails connus
qui ont prêté leur voix aux différents
personnages des têtes connues donc
pascal légitimus ciranoé oldelaf quand
peut-on le voir ce spectacle
le dernier jour est à découvrir à samedi
31 mars à 17h donc aux clayes-sous-bois
et s'adresse aux enfants à partir de 6
ans et les places vont de 5 à 10 euros
et ce même